is Jesus dependent on the father or
independent on the Father the answer is
both did you catch it the answer is both
Jesus is independent from the father and
dependent on the father did you catch it
now I'm going to show you why that's a
mistake look at the mistake watch here
but we have to properly understand who
Jesus is if we mean the Eternal second
person of the Trinity who has existed
for all time then he is independent of
the father in the sense not being a
dependent
creature that absolutely does not help
to make any sense so yes he's
independent of the father in the sense
that he's not a dependent
creature so you're saying he's not
dependent as a creature because he's not
created but nonetheless as God is he
dependent on the father or
not and I'm going to explain to you the
proper biblical answer
the probab and I'm going to turn it
against the Muslims pay attention pray
the Lord will sharpen me to avoid my
mistakes and learn from their mistakes
and you avoid all these mistakes and
perfect our theology okay now let's let
him finish the Bible teaches this in
Colossians 1 and in John chapter one
that God is the Creator and Jesus is
that God but when Jesus Takes on human
flesh we see him sweat and eat and sleep
and as a human being he then becomes
dependent upon God so he set up a straw
man and failed to understand what we
mean by the Trinity and actually what's
meant by the Incarnation okay let me
stop right there okay let me now correct
the bad theology number
one number one you ask for clarification
of terms what do you mean
independent do you mean that the father
son Holy Spirit can exist separately
separately and apart from one another no
they cannot why because they are
inseparably the one God it's like me
asking the Muslim okay watch here the
Sunni Muslim because they're Sunni
Muslim the Quran is it the speech of
Allah pay attention Brethren the Quran
is it the speech of Allah yes they call
it
Allah Allah meaning the speech of Allah
and as the speech it's one of the
attributes of Allah are Allah's
attributes uncreated yes are they
beginningless yes do they exist
separately from Allah no are they
independent from Allah no can Allah
exist without his attributes no can
Allah exist without a speech no that
means Allah cannot exist without the
Quran you see there's an interdependency
right you understand so can Allah exist
apart from his attributes no attributes
are inseparable from Allah can the
attributes of Allah exist independently
of Allah no so is the Quran Allah's
speech Yes is it one of his attributes
yes can Allah exist apart from the Quran
no so Allah depends on the Quran just as
much as the Quran depends on
Allah now coming back to the Trinity the
father is not independent of his son the
word or his breath the spirit because
the father cannot be God and cannot
truly be the father without and apart
from the Son and the spirit so the son
is independent of creation but is
inseparable from the father and the
spirit the spirit is independent of
creation but Inseparable from the father
and the son and the father is
independent of creation he doesn't need
creation but he's Inseparable from the
Son and the spirit because the father
cannot be God and cannot be who he is
without the Son and the spirit
you get my
point that's the
answer they are independent of
creation but they cannot be what they
are and God cannot be God without father
son Spirit eternally inseparably
existing together so the father cannot
be God and cannot be who he is without
the Son and the spirit the son cannot be
God cannot be who he is without the
father and the spirit the spirit cannot
be the cannot be God cannot be who he is
without the father and the son and the
Muslims have the same dilemma so let me
repeat how do you turn against Muslims
and I'm going to give you scripture to
prove it you ask the Muslim Allah's
attributes are they independent of
Allah no can they exist apart from Allah
no can Allah exist independently of his
attributes no can Allah exist without
attributes no secondly is the Quran one
of Allah's attributes the sunnis will
say yes his
speech can the Quran exist apart from
Allah no is it independent from Allah no
can Allah exist without a speech no
therefore Allah cannot exist without the
Quran so Allah needs the Quran the Quran
needs Allah so now where do I get Father
and Son Spirit cannot exist
independently separately they can only
exist
together
inseparably so one cannot be who he is
and what he is without the others I'm
getting it from the Bible here here it
is let me show you John 5 19- 21 so that
was a bad
answer John 5 19 to 21 you
ready from scripture the early church
follows the right Jesus said to them
truly truly I say to you the son can do
nothing of his inord now he's not
talking as a man man he's talking as the
Divine person who's in flesh because
he's going to talk about doing things
that only God can
do how do I know watch but only what he
sees the father doing for whatever he
does the that the son does likewise now
let me ask you a question can a creature
say I can only do what God does and I
can do whatever God does the way God
does it because notice what Jesus said
pay attention carefully what he said I
cannot do a single thing of my own
initiative I can only do what I see the
father doing and whatever he does I do
it in the same way what creature can say
I can only do what God does and I do
what God does the way God does it no
creature can say that because a creature
does a lot of things God wouldn't do and
a creature cannot do everything that God
does because God does things that only
God can
do so you see the
Inseparable essential Unity they are
inseparable but because they're one God
their power is one they can do all
things that only God can do because they
are the one God and here's proof that's
what Jesus is saying here let's read the
rest of
it let's read the rest of
it for the father loves the son and
shows them all that he himself is doing
so everything the father is doing the
son is doing they're doing it together
and the spirit joins them so all three
are acting continuously simultaneously
doing the same things together right
even though they're not the same person
a mystery beyond our ability to fully
comprehend so the father will show him
more things that he does that you may
Marvel now here what are the things that
the father does that Jesus does in the
same way which only God can do for as
the father
raises the dead and gives them life so
also the son giv gives life to whom he
will the sovereignty of the son the
independence of the son from creation
and the dependence of creation on the
son because the son is the one who gives
life and he gives it to whom he wants so
he doesn't need creation creation needs
him but still in relationship to the
father and spirit they're Inseparable so
learn your theology learn what the
Trinity teaches and doesn't teach can do
nothing on my own accord as I hear I
judge and my judgment is just because I
seek not my own will but the will of him
who sent me because the father's will is
the son's will the spirit's will the
father's judgment is the son's judgment
the spirit's
judgment right okay few more so you can
learn properly what you're supposed to
believe and not believe from scripture
we're not making it up we're deriving is
from scripture John 8
28-29 John 8:
28-29 so Jesus said when you have lifted
up the son of
man when he dies buried resurrects and
ascends into his glory then you will
know that I am he now watch and that I
do nothing on my own authority but speak
thus as the father taught me I only do
what the father does and what the father
tells me to do because they're
Inseparable and he who sent me is with
me why he has not let me alone why for I
always do not sometime not most of the
time every second every minute for all
eternity I'm always doing what is
pleasing to him impossible for a mere
creature to say John 8229 we got a few
more because even the holy spirit is
involved in this John 12
49-50 John 1249 to
50 see being popular doesn't mean you're
qualified and being qualified doesn't
make you popular John 1249 to 5050 for I
have not spoken on my my own authority
for the father who sent me has himself
given me commandment what to say and
what to speak the perfect in separable
Union of the godhead it's not just Jesus
as man speaking it's the Divine logos
the Divine hupostasis the person that
Divine person as a Divine person can
only do and say what the father does and
says because they're
Inseparable because he says the same
thing about the Holy Spirit the Holy
Spirit never never became
flesh the Holy Spirit never became flesh
and yet the same thing said about the
spirit I'm going show that to you
next give me a commandment what to say
and what to speak and I know that his
commandment is eternal life right John
12:
49:50 what I
say therefore I say as the father has
bidden me now the Holy Spirit not become
flesh so you can't say it's the Holy
Spirit speaking as a man Jesus says the
same thing about the Holy Spirit look
John 16
12-13 John 16
12-13 John 161 12-13 I have yet many
things to say to you but you cannot bear
them now when the spirit of truth comes
he will guide you into all truth why for
he will not speak on his own authority
on his own
initiative same thing Jesus said I do
not act on my own authority neither does
the spirit but whatever he hears he will
speak and he will declare to you the
things that are to come now the Holy
Spirit did not become flesh he didn't
become a man so you can't say oh Jesus
as a man speaking no no no it's the
Divine son the Divine logos
speaking son and spirit whether the son
is Incarnate or before he became flesh
son and spirit are inseparably perfectly
United to the father and one another so
they can only act in perfect Unity this
is a statement about their nature and
their relationship to one another not
the Incarnation per
se because someone say oh it's Jesus as
a man speaking no he says the same thing
about the Holy Spirit the spirit will
not speak on his own authority he'll
only speak what he hears and only say
what he hears it's referring to their
divine nature and how they relate to one
another okay
you got it